violence continues outside the US
Embassy in Iraq this morning
demonstrators led by iranian-backed
militias are protesting for a second
straight day the Pentagon's released new
video of Marines arriving at the site
the protests followed deadly US
airstrikes responding to an attack that
killed a u.s. contractor in Florida last
night President Trump said he does not
want war with Iran chief Washington
correspondent major Garrett asked the
president Secretary of State Mike Pompeo
about Iran in an exclusive interview
should the American people contemplate
being on a war footing in 2020 where
Iran is concerned this is
state-sponsored terror
this is Iranian backed terrorism that
took place that threatened American
interests we've taken a fundamentally
different approach we have starved them
of resources we've denied them access
we've put pressure on the Iranian
leadership and I think you see that this
morning a Ron Supreme Leader strongly
condemned the u.s. attacks in Iraq Holly
Williams is tracking the violence in
Baghdad Holly good morning good morning
those protestors outside the US Embassy
in Baghdad again this morning have been
throwing rocks and setting fire to an
American flag Marines have deployed from
their base in nearby Kuwait to reinforce
security the truth from the 82nd
Airborne Division will be deployed to
the Middle East in coming days and last
night us Apache helicopters dropped
flares in a show of force American
personnel inside the embassy are safe
according to the State Department and
there are no evacuation plans but the
violent protestors were able to enter
the supposedly high-security Green Zone
in Baghdad under the noses of Iraqi
security forces raising questions about
their complicity the demonstrations were
led by militia groups with backing from
Iran
America is now vying with Iran for
influence over Iraq tensions that some
fear could become a full-blown proxy war
Adriana Holly Williams in Turkey thank
you
you